et cette nuit je dors très tôt que je
regarde le us open
voilà tous les soirs donc je me couche
je me réveille tôt parce que pour
regarder des matchs au tennis et bien
d'autres gynéco a fait une vidéo où ils
insultent et l'ecofin et magda les sacs
sur ce compte instagram où ils pensent
que vous êtes des mises et oui voilà
c'est voilà ce qu'on a monté c'était
bout des tractions à regarder ça avec
ses magnifiques quoi cette histoire il
faut leur garde mais j'ai mangé au
contraire je suis à jeun et ben vous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé
monsieur naulleau je sais pas exactement
ce prix là il s'est déguisé dans un
singe et ses nuits dans il a été maître
un costume de singe et il a inventé une
rubrique existait pas il a inventé un
parc d'attractions qui n'existaient pas
donc voilà il n'y a pas de bananes il
n'y a pas de
y'a pas de parc où les gens font
grossièrement
on grossièrement accent africain ça
n'existe pas là déjà c'est beaucoup plus
clair